[Music]
I think of you as almost like the love
child of David Bronner and Zack Bush
with a light dusting of the happy pair
twins like you've got the conscious
capitalism sacred Commerce thing going
on you've got the regenerative
agriculture thing going on and then you
leverage these cafes these restaurants
to amplify this positive vibe that
you're putting out into the world and
they serve as kind of these ground zeros
like the locusts for all the things that
you care about to cultivate community
and provide you know expansive wisdom in
the world like how do you think about
what you do Wow thank you for that
question
and for that that creation story for me
you could disagree yeah no you know it
the way that I the way that want I just
I've had an incredibly privileged life
just in the extraordinary parents and
that I've gotten to work with my parents
and I would say that yeah really my the
way I see it is I've had an
extraordinarily lucky life and
upbringing and opportunity and access to
people and things and information and
really part of my struggle has been how
do i best use that privilege to be to
serve and to contribute mm-hmm and you
know i would say that the big kind of
essence of my life and the crux of my
life has really been how do i be
the presence of love such that everyone
I come in contact with they're left with
that love was not not something that was
found but actually is something that we
embody and that we we offer and we give
that you know that was kind of the
biggest spiritual epiphany of my life
was that love is not something found in
a person place or thing it's something
that is and we've heard many versions of
this before but it's something that is
ever-present in our heart and it's
always available as a gift and it cost
nothing to share it and yes we have lots
of things that get in the way of that
but as you know I think if if I was to
die tomorrow what I would want people to
know and what I would hope that I
demonstrated to to a fair men and the
interactions that I've had would be like
wow there was there was love present
that was being given freely from that
human being
mmm so difficult to hold on to God well
your Twitter your Twitter bio kind of
says it all right your Twitter bio is
unconditional love remembering the
unconditional part mmm that's the hard
part right the additional part oh my god
Wow Wow
yeah thank you for that lesson that I I
said and thought and you know many many
years ago when I wrote that um yeah so
yeah really I would say that what Cafe
Gratitude what kissed the ground
everything that I'm doing really is how
to connect to that brilliance and that
spirit of love and then take action
guided from that and I where does where
does this come from I mean this does
this come downstream from amazing
parents like where does that sensibility
emanate for
yeah definitely I'm where many people I
think had a relationship to specific
religions or spiritualities really what
I remember of my upbringing was
basically the the the communication was
that we were all we're all cells in one
body and that there's this yeah that
world that we're all one so how do you
take action and how do you treat each
other and the earth knowing that where
they are you are there too so how would
you treat how would you be towards them
mm-hmm and so that was that was like a
foundational piece and then you know I
kind of rebelled and went away from my
parents I tried to become a pro
snowboarder for a couple years in lake
tahoe and kind of had a you know I got
to go figure out my life on my own and
then you know my sister got in a
situation where she was facing life
imprisonment based around a marijuana
deal gone bad I didn't know her and I
basically had to I left my life and Lake
Tahoe came to kind of be with her in LA
to kind of get her through this moment
and that ended up going turning into a
we ended up opening a recording studio
in North Hollywood so I had this whole
career or like a hip-hop R&B really
recording so you say you sound like a
like a like a kind of a Porto Rican
chinstrap and like wore FUBU velour
jumpsuits very hard time visualizing and
at a major swagger how long ago was that
this is in mm mm mm I was 20 20 20 21 22
and 23
uh-huh but at some point you found your
way back to the family home yeah then
then that
business fell apart and I actually had
one a big moment of kind of humility and
loss because we had built this recording
studio we had three recording zoos in
North Hollywood and we were totally hip
to the scene of you know urban hip-hop
music and had a lot of artists that you
know we um you know the Rough Riders you
know like Jadakiss was in the studio
Ashanti was in the studio b2k back in
the day you know they were so it was
like this big moment and then literally
we lost everything we had to sell our
house we had bought and I ended up being
like the host at follow your heart in
Canoga Park and I remember the first
time one of the celebrities this woman
named janae who's like a budding R&B
celebrity like came in to follow your
heart and I was like the thank you for
choosing follow your heart is Rylan and
she knew me as this young studio Hunter
manure from a year before and just like
the dying to my bride of what happened
you just got upside down on it yeah I
mean we basically took a huge I took a
huge loan or owner financing for the
building we took a huge loan on the
equipment was like $500,000 worth of
equipment our monthly and that was like
$40,000 and you know when Napster took
you know the internet kind of media
share music sharing became a thing
budgets really went and so there was no
you could pretty much record something
in a studio at home versus needing a big
live room and this kind of thing so that
whole thing fell apart and my sister
went into a state of depression I had to
get a job and follow your heart I was
always into health food organic people
are listening all your heart is like
super old-school like an OG like vegan
macrobiotic restaurant slash grocery
store like deep in the valley where I
ate there recently it's been there since
the seventies feels like the wood panel
or it looks exactly like it did back in
the day and has
that aesthetic yeah like they were
selling avocado and sprout sandwiches
when it was sixty cents for a sandwich
yeah I'm sure it was like the only
vegetarian vegan restaurant in the whole
area it's crazy
follow your heart is now you know huge
because vegenaise vegenaise and all
their assorted products cheese yeah yeah
that's crazy
but yeah we where we were getting to was
and other other things you know the
other cool you know this is I guess full
transparency my folks took me to a a
plant medicine ceremony at 19 years old
at a moment in my life when I was
totally in identity crisis of what I was
supposed to do I didn't go to college
because I had learning disabilities as a
child had ADHD and attention deficit
disorder and dyslexia had read it like a
fifth-grade level graduating high school
and so I was and I didn't go to college
so I didn't think I was equipped for
further education and then the whole
dot-com boom was happening in San
Francisco I was living on the west coast
and I was thinking I should get into
that and and you know I was kind of in
conflict of where I should go and what I
should do and then I ended up drinking
ayahuasca with your parents with my
parents Wow
and yeah I had this amazing clear
pathway which was I saw my you know
desire for you know fascination with
technology or need to do that because
that was the thing that where people
were making money and I just saw
visually you know the kind of corrosive
disconnected more disconnected nature
that going down that road would take me
and take humanity and I visually saw
myself as this my hands you know as
roots and my shoulders as the sides of
the mountains and you know this
protector of the earth and in this you
know very beautiful moment experiencing
myself as a being as the Earth
feeling that pulse of life from you know
the earth and then experiencing even
another dimension of you know the view
from the the bird's-eye view of you know
me and the earth all experiencing itself
as this you know one experience and and
what I came away with it my life was
about protecting and caring for Mother
Earth Wow and that's what you've become
that's what yeah yeah that was a
predecessor moment and again that there
was you know many many many many years
until you know kissed the ground but you
know again the the background of that
was I was always I always knew that
plant medicine whether it was echinacea
or Golden Seal or you know these
different herbs or you know I was a type
of kid who someone get a sting a bee
sting and I would go and find a plantain
you know weed on chew it up in my mouth
and make a green little lump of and
stick that on the bee sting and knew
that it would pull it pull the pull the
poison out of this right so I always say
there was a background of it but it
became very clear that that was what I
was - that that was the master and the
mother that I was supposed to serve so
growing up then did you grow up on your
parents farm mmm I mean your dad was
originally like an IBM executive right
and then like switch gears like no no
totally wrong my dad actually didn't go
to college
we didn't my dad was my dad wasn't back
to the lander he spent three years in
the adder on tank on Adirondack
Mountains in a teepee cooking every meal
on wood fire and then I was conceived
right at the end of that phase when they
were on their way to California in a
little hippie van oh how I find their TM
meditation teacher their guru a guy
named Charlie Lutz
I got conceived on that road trip that's
cuz I mean like you know truth is
stranger than fiction right like if you
scripted that or that was in a movie
you'd be like there's no way it's to
California it's like - hippie totally
Wow
so they Anu
they end up getting out there and then
not being able to sustain themselves and
because they were pregnant they realized
oh I have a kid on the way we have to go
back and it ourselves you know sort it
out and so they went it up ended up
going back to upstate New York we ended
up my dad and his brother married my mom
and her twin sister no way
so two brothers married sisters lived in
this we're this little farm house in
upstate New York on 21 acres with a
little pond a little orchard it was old
dairy barn one one pocket but one bank
account between the four and you know
that's where that's where we grew up
utopia uh yeah always grew up until how
old uh until eighteen oh so I went all
through high school it was was in you go
to like a local high school or were you
homeschooled we went to I went to
Waldorf School for the first till eighth
grade and then went to a alternative
public school called ACS mmm which had
courses classes like radical American
politics and you read Howard Zinn
people's history Wow
so how did they how did how did this
group of four make their way uh my dad
was he calls himself he was a piss-poor
a carpenter like a b-grade part part
carpenter and my uncle Scott he raised
dairy cows and my my my mom's my aunt
worked at the coop you know green star
coop and my mom's first company was the
benevolent bean gene the bean and she
made tempeh and tofu as the first
business and it had a big soybean on the
back of a van was there's a little their
car and and then that kind of you know
that was short-lived and then my dad my
dad didn't mom started a clothing
business called flax right that was kind
of their first success mm-hmm and they
built that kind of from you know in the
sewing room in our house too
they were selling to thousands of
retailers all across the county well and
is that where the affirmations began the
affirmations began with my parents
different spiritual teachers there was a
woman named Jan Kenny or Jan Williams
and she was a big part of this whole
idea that your life is a picture of your
mind and that we are creators of our
reality through our thoughts speech
beliefs actions and attitudes create our
reality and if we're just present to
managing our thoughts speech beliefs
actions and attitudes you know we can
you know really have a Dominion in the
experience of our life mm-hmm and and
that spirit amplifies if so if I'm if
I'm if I'm complaining spirit is gonna
amplify that complaint into my reality
because spirit is neutral it's just
amplifying what we what we are putting
our awareness on in the present moment
and so you know that and that was an
interesting thing because they got way
deep into that work to the point where
you know there was affirmations all over
house my first name was regal relating
Ryland
it was my it was my affirmation no name
and so you're being you're being
indoctrinated into this from as far back
as you can remember right it's kind of
amazing that you actually didn't become
like an investment banker I suppose I
I would I would imagine that the
ayahuasca ceremony probably was the
wrench in that plan because usually a
kid that grows up in an environment
that's so loose and progressive in that
way ends up going in the opposite
direction to rebel yeah
needing to find structure because it was
no structure right there's chaos with
that totally right there yeah absolutely
absolutely so when you but when you look
back on that you would like what are you
what's your emotional reaction to it I
mean you sound I mean you come across
like you're very fond of that the way
you were brought up yeah I
you know I still my relationship to both
my dad and mom even though my mom and
dad a you know divorce they divorced
when I was 20 and I'm yeah I adore them
there's some of my favorite people in
the world I work with my dad Cafe
Gratitude
you know he's a regenerative farmer and
yeah he were work were each other's
biggest fans well I met them I know if
you remember this we went to
Thanksgiving at gracias Madre it's
probably two years two years ago yeah
yes and you you guys put on this amazing
experience where you had Native American
singers and danced there was like all
kinds of really cool stuff though the
parents were there and I had a nice
conversation with your dad yes then we
were all people who we were raising
every Thanksgiving we do a free meal for
the community and we choose a cause to
have you know it's like our way you know
Thanksgiving Cafe Gratitude gracias
Madre it's all about you know thanked
thankfulness being thankful being
grateful and so our way to kind of be
who we say we are and you know really
emanate like gratitude and generosity is
we do a free day where we serve you know
somewhere between 800 and thousand meals
and we choose a cause to have all you
know we don't charge people but we ask
for donations and all those donations go
to some cause in that year was the year
of the earthquake in Oaxaca right right
and we end up raising somewhere between
1015 thousand bucks and I said well yeah
so yeah it's fun so you're in upstate
New York the affirmations are happening
yeah exactly so yeah so what do you my
parents are you know at this point
they're totally like dirt poor hippies
then and my dad is practicing literally
he has got like a an 82 like Renault
like a super you know like with with
with like rot like you know in on the
East Coast and the winter times you know
the the floor and and literally he's got
little sticky notes all the house go
that's a magnificent millionaire math
this is literally what he's programming
himself magnifica and being how would a
millionaire be and he's being you know
millionaire Matthew magnificent
millionaire Matthew uh-huh which all you
know also had a lot to do with you know
like when being generous you know we
demonstrate you know when we're giving
we become you know open receptacles to
receive you know in in this in this idea
of you know just always looking at how
we can be generous and you know when we
you know we can't outgive the universe
so if we're just if we're if we're
putting our bet on generosity then you
know we have this and and willing to
stay open you know the the philosophy or
the idea is that that generosity because
if there's one 'no Stan where we're
giving will ultimately come back to us
as well well the beautiful thing is that
all of that became manifest it all
became true like I would I would think
like if you're in that moment and you're
in the Renault and you're like seeing
the reality in the current situation
you're like this guy's insane right like
but like look what has blossomed out of
this like all of that became true and
more significantly you know the cultural
impact that you and your your family
your siblings have had on the world is
really remarkable
so those principles are truisms but
they're on their own timeline yes right
totally so so how do you end up making
your way out to California then does the
family relocate so yeah so I moved
before I at 18 I got in my little Toyota
stick-shift Toyota Corolla with one of
my best friends we moved to the west
coast again I was seeking snowboarding
like trying to Punk pro snowboarder
lived a couple years in lake tahoe then
did three years in LA on the commercial
recording studio business that all fell
apart then kind of little a year of
transition with follow heart you know
getting back into food and healthy food
actually I forgot to say when I was
working in Lake Tahoe trying to be a pro
snowboarder I became the assistant
kitchen manager of the Sugar Bowl Lodge
ski resort so I was always savvy with
and that was actually because my parents
because they were building a business
they were leaving us home alone a lot as
kids and you know we had things like
umeboshi plums and hijiki seaweed and
tofu con and you know so I just you know
I got you know basically got creative
with ingredients and became very
self-sufficient as far as producing food
and I've always had a knack for you know
putting ingredients together and yeah so
so recording studio follow your heart
and then and then I was kind of had
another moment of losing my way and
basically humbled myself I was I was I
started taking acting classes in LA I
had like that la crisis where I like
started to dry out yeah let me see if I
can find my self-importance by being an
actor uh-huh so I I did that and started
taking the chronic oh did you give any
gigs no no no I just mostly got about a
year into classes in a small you know
box theater next to the guitar Center on
Hollywood Boulevard
okay salary so so then I kind of humbled
myself and just you know literally
called my dad and kind of tears like I
don't know what I'm doing I'm kind of
lost
I'd love to come back I knew that they
were starting to develop Cafe Gratitude
and I I called him up and asked him you
know I'd love to come back and learn the
business so that was the other thing I
had a very serious relationship here
with a woman and so I was like can I
come back and learn the business in a
year or two and come back and open Cafe
Gratitude in LA and they said you know
you know of course my father wanted me
son waiting for that for totally right
but he knew you had to go on this like
epic hero's journey no no in order to
come back to the fold that's right it's
very so at what point did the first Cafe
Gratitude in San Francisco open that was
the first one right first one was 20th
in Harrison in the Mission District I'm
sure you went
and it was you know like 1400 square
feet hand-painted signs over the door it
said a world of Plenty home of the
abounding river board game because most
people don't know is that Cafe Gratitude
and all the the kind of eccentricities
of the affirmations on the menu and the
question of the day and the kind of
jubilant joyful energy and attitude all
comes from a board game that Matthew and
Tara see created they spent a year
creating this very in-depth kind of
transformational spiritual board game
similar to monopoly or life but instead
of buying and selling
you know hotels and charging fuel to
stay in them you ask people about where
are you feeling unworthy and having each
player share where they're feeling
unworthy and then say three things that
you love about yourself to the person to
your left and the original Cafe
Gratitude we it was a transformational
gaming parlor where we served raw vegan
food uh-huh so literally it was you know
it said on the above the front door home
of the abounding river board game and
every table in the restaurant there was
no individual two top tables everything
was a community table that I knew and
and every table had embedded and
lacquered in was this game and there was
cards and basically the server didn't
just just take your order they also
encouraged you to play the game and
teach you how to play the game I
actually had a position for a while in
the company called the game Meister
where I was just there facilitated whole
restaurant was really this this play to
just get people in and under the rubric
of serving them food but also get them
to engage with this game and go on this
kind of like philosophical existential
inquiry totally I mean that was
literally it that wow that literally was
you know what came first the chicken or
the egg the gratitude piece the food was
literally the carrot to get people in
the door right so that we could ask them
the question what are you grateful for
so we could play a an invitational role
in shifting a
to gratitude what year did it opus was
2000 2003 member before March of 2004 I
had I was living in San Francisco up
until 90 when did I move down here
96 9 yeah like like almost 1997 and then
after living here for a couple years I
started to hear rumors about this place
Cafe Gratitude and it almost sounded
apocryphal like there's this place and
you go and then you had the the the bowl
was at the community ball grateful
grateful Bowl where you could just pay
whatever you felt like paying and quite
often you were just giving it away and I
was like what is going on here you know
and there was almost this myth about
this utopian food place yeah reaching
far and wide yeah that the Grateful Bowl
came in 2007 or eight when the economy
took a collapse and it was Christmas
morning and me and my dad were sitting
on Beulah farm and kind of inquiry you
know inquiring into how can we
demonstrate our our doubling down on
generosity at a moment when everyone's
feeling contracted and how can we step
into having organic food not just be for
the affluent and you know thinking about
like you know the blue-plate special--
what could we do and we realized that of
all the affirmations on the menu there
was no I am grateful mm-hmm and we were
like oh perfect we're gonna create the
great football and it'll be a sliding
scale and we'll serve you know will
communicate look some who pay some can
pay more some can pay less and will
experiment with can the community take
care of each other through you know
those that have more will pay more and
those that have less will pay less than
it will balance out to where at least it
covers the food cost is that how it
played out well we did it we've done it
we continued to do it to this day and
the great football is still available
it's now
subsidized price of seven bucks to go so
you can go in and get one to go at seven
bucks you know the challenge then became
you had a lot of people coming in you
know parties of four getting a $0.50
great football and then servers were you
know depending on the income so it you
know the ripple effect became challenged
to do it as you know part of a full
services full service experience but
we've today served over 800,000 bowls at
under five bucks Wow and I had the most
moving meaningful moment where I was at
this seminar in Culver City and this
gentleman came up to me and he had heard
that I was from Cafe Gratitude and he
said I just want to thank you because I
lived in Auckland grew raising three
kids at a time in my life when I had you
know no money and you know I know how
important nutrition is in the form of
years of raising children and
essentially we had fast-food liquor
stores and Cafe Gratitude is great
football and I was able to raise my kid
children on you know great footballs and
we'd go there a couple times a week and
that's what it's about and I was moved
and I was moved and so you know at the
end of the day did it work out exactly
the way that we wanted no not you know
did we ended up closing you know we had
we had a restaurant in the Oakland CAF
are the Oakland Whole Foods a small
little kiosk Cafe Gratitude and we
called it cafe grateful bulk how it's
pretty much what everyone got and we you
know and we we did it for probably five
years mm-hmm
and ultimately that unit per se or that
restaurant didn't you know lead you know
wasn't successful but ultimately you
know all the alchemy of that generosity
and the forward movement and development
of the company leads us to where we are
today so yeah I feel and today you've
got what six or seven how many places do
seven restaurant seven in Southern
California and then we
have one kind of hippie handshake
anomaly restaurant in Kansas City
there's a Cafe Gratitude and you know in
Kansas City that's kind of more like the
original cafe gratitudes as far as in
design aesthetic and menu was the Santa
Cruz one exactly and my brother and
that's actually called grateful for
Santa Cruz so it's no longer a Cafe
Gratitude but it's got to be recent I
was there maybe two years ago or yeah
like that was called cafe great that's
it it was just in the last eight months
maybe a year it's been called grateful
for Santa Cruz but they still have
there's a lot of the same thing still
you still kind of feel like you're in a
cafe got to do they are yeah
and for those people that are listening
that I've never had the experience of
going to a cafe gratitude you may not
play a board game when you when you eat
there but you will be greeted by your
your waitstaff person who will say would
you like to hear the question of the day
that question will be presented and then
every item on the menu and that question
is usually some version of what are you
grateful for what are you passionate
about what moves you from your head to
your heart yeah something that drops us
into a likely a more meaningful
conversation if we if we're willing to
be if we're willing to go there it
oftentimes can stimulate some you know
potent and powerful commerce right and
then every item on the menu is an
affirmation I am fill in the blank yeah
so if you want a mint chocolate chip
shake which has been around for since
day one it's our number one seller you
say I am cool and then when the server
brings it out to you they say you are a
cool or you are passionate or you are
loved or you are kind or you are
grateful
are you a grateful yeah and again you
know we we the way we see that is we see
it is is playful we don't take ourselves
too seriously but we do see the positive
impact of creating a space that uses
language intentionally to to uplift
people and to remind people of their
greatness you know well it's it's sort
of a small thing but it's also quite
proof
like what I see in that is listen when
you sit down to have a meal with another
human being or even with yourself like
this is a sacred act that dates back to
the beginning of humankind obviously are
all animal kind and we should treat it
as such so let's establish a paradigm
that can be conducive to a meaningful
exchange between people and when you set
it up like I am this or here's the
question of the day you're basically
saying here's what I here's perhaps a
subject matter that you can explore over
the next hour or two rather than like
the you know the surface level nonsense
that we tend to talk about totally I
think there was a what are those the
kids in the hall what was that Britta
there was British there was a good kid I
think I was Canadian wasn't it you made
me yeah and there was this like kind of
a classic comedy thing where was like
this spoof on formal fine dining and
they basically you know describe what
you're eating tonight and what you'll be
talking about so that was like our one
way to see it is like we're playfully
inviting people to enjoy and be
nourished by healthy organic plant-based
food and potentially have a conversation
about gratitude right so talk to me
about the sacred commerce aspect of all
this beautiful yeah so again we've we've
somewhat communicated that you know as
the way that customers come in and have
this experience with the restaurant but
my parents definitely were you know
they're they're they're revolutionaries
they're they they're forward-thinking
you know beyond the mundane and I I just
you know so admire and honor their
efforts and their intention and their
commitment and conviction but yeah they
didn't only just they've written a book
and they've led many many workshops on
the principles of sacred Commerce which
is the principles or the basic messages
how can you run a business and also
awaken the presence of love and that's a
very very
difficult razor's edge to walk on and
it's sort of like an advanced degree in
conscious capitalism it's like taking
conscious capitalism an additional step
that's right and it's exactly that
because conscious capitalism is the
triple bottom line people planet profit
we said sacred Commerce is you get if
you have to get a pass so it's a acronym
PA SS profitability awakening
sustainability and social justice or
service so you know profitability we see
that again we're not a non-profit we're
a for-profit profitable businesses if we
want you know capitalism to get excited
about this it's got to be profitable and
profitability is like the health or the
immune system of a organization because
you know life is gonna have ups and
downs peaks and valleys and if we
haven't had you know profitable business
we're gonna have a rainy day and it's
gonna collapse the whole you know you
can't achieve any or other goals yeah
that's right so essential awakening is
you know the aspect of you know we are
committed to the employee or what we
call advocate experience working in our
restaurants that you are learning new
language that there's you know
communication style there's the way that
we are managing and the way that we're
coaching and the way that we're guiding
our advocates or employees is a way that
has them be empowered for instance we
have 10 tools for creating a grateful
community which are part of the sacred
commerce toolkit and those tools are
tools like acknowledgement and that
acknowledgement is not just about seeing
someone doing a good job and then saying
you clean your room good job it's about
seeing the the unexpressed qualities of
curiosity of courage of of of wisdom of
kindness and actually saying alright we
want it we want to call
today and grow the those virtuous
qualities in human beings and so we're
going to we're gonna acknowledge have
have to be a culture of acknowledgement
where we're just always looking for how
can we see someone see their greatness
see their potential and call that forth
in our acknowledgement so the way that
that shows up is we have a process that
we've been doing since day one called
clearing which is essentially two
questions
sounds like Scientology is not right but
essentially it's just two questions one
question and over the years the clearing
process had has has had many iterations
but in its most pure form it was two
questions first question could be you
know what are you struggling with or
where are you experiencing self-doubt or
and again this goes back to the game and
essentially it's allowing a person to
just share you know what is distracting
them from their the present moment
mm-hmm because we know that the best
service and the best you know if we're
if we're talking about you know customer
experience and customer service we want
our people to be present and if they're
if we're distracted by some story of
self-doubts you know some frustration
some irritation and we can actually have
a five-minute process before their shift
such that they can shift their attention
to some aspect of something that they do
have an abundance of something that they
do can't they are grateful for and then
end that process with an acknowledgement
then you know that ultimately is lifting
them up breathing some you know life
into their wings and then hopefully that
that kindness that presence that
listening you know we we oftentimes are
so starved for someone to really give us
like are they're full listening and so
just a couple minutes of having someone
be heard not trying to fix or change
them but just reflecting back what we
heard them say
and then saying the second question
which would be what are you grateful for
and you know we'll just ask you really
grateful for today I'm grateful to be
having this experience with you right
now amazing well I just would love to
acknowledge you for the quality of your
listening and the quality of your
presence it's really it's an easy space
to share into so thank you I appreciate
that Ryland you're making my job very
I'm doing my job for me but is this is
this something so this is something you
do for all of the staff we have an
aspiration to have every staff member
have a clearing process before they
start you know it's I'm just imagining
the person who's like look man I just
needed it like a dishwasher job like I'm
not I'm not signing up for all this yeah
crazy [ __ ] totally people lot lots of
resistance and ultimately you know what
the clearing has kind of evolved into is
you know because we asked the question
of the day which is always the second
question of the clearing is the question
that then we extend to our guests so
that question becomes asked around the
house and then you know on a good day
people you know rich you know what are
you grateful for awesome on an
acknowledge you for you know being an
amazing team member today they are
coming in let's have a great shift um so
it used to be like five minutes per
person like write it down and you know
over the years that's evolved to what we
call clearing on the court is asking
each other the question of the day and
then acknowledging each other for
something that we appreciate about one
another and ultimately that creating a
space for or that creating a quality of
human experience that creates what
people have called the vibe at Cafe
Gratitude there's a vibe and that is you
know there definitely is you go in there
you feel good everybody who's working
there looks you in the eye like they
seem present they are listening like it
is different from your typical
restaurant experience totally and you
know we've we've put a lot of energy and
a lot of money in
time effort and you know the other
things like you know we have all
advocate meetings which are just
meetings where we put everybody in a
room together we have translators for
the back of the house spanish-speaking
folks and essentially it's just some
nugget of inspiration wisdom life
knowledge you know some of the stuff
that you teach here or you share with
your guests on this show will have that
be you know present or communicated like
I've had marianne williamson come in and
talk to our staff before and so yeah so
you know again and then another thing
one of the benefits that we've offered
people again in the aspect of you know
awaken your transformation we've paid
for people to do the Landmark Forum
which is a transformational weekend
course that many people have heard of if
you'll probably haven't heard of but
it's essentially a three-day personal
growth self empowerment course that
happens all over the world and not that
we have any affiliate i with them it's
just a course that we've seen in three
short days excuse me three short days
provides you know tremendous
transformation value my parents did it
many years ago but it was very impactful
in a positive way for them I've never
been myself I know tons of people that
have done it and have benefited
tremendously from that experience but it
but there's an aspect of that that got
you guys in like a little bit of a
sticky wicket back in the day with the
San Francisco restaurant right are you
like no can I write about this and I'm
like I don't
I'm confused like I don't unders I don't
understand why it's such a big like
Landmark Forum is pretty mainstream yeah
like you know talk about not super
fringe I mean you know we as a company
have done a lot more fringe things and
you know encouraging Landmark Education
but ya haven't got kept my gratitude has
definitely been a you know we've been uh
kind of a hotbed for you know suspicion
of Kulthum um and what is this sacred
commerce thing that's lame and like
what's the what is the agenda here
totally
there is a some rumor that you had to
get to working cavity I did yet to get a
beloved tattoo so fans that are just
listening you roll up your sleeves and
you have B on your left forearm and love
on your right forearm and yeah me and my
dad went and got those together oh yeah
right after we went did a immense new
Warrior Training weekend ah where where
I was like all right you know it was
kind of like how are you gonna be how
are you gonna demonstrate masculinity in
the world and the thing that came to me
was like all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
be loved and I'm gonna have loving be a
masculine thing that I actually love is
sourced from within me and I can't never
be taken away from me and that that
actually is a beautiful masculine
quality they are you yes so so yeah so
they I mean yes Cafe Gratitude
over the years because we we you know we
were we were super I mean there was a
moment when you know I kind of feel like
this is almost like talking back in the
day like in the 60s and 70s it was like
a moment when Cafe Gratitude was you
know when business went down and we
would have all employee meetings and we
do ah meditations for abundance for the
restaurant and for all of our lives like
we'd get all of our employees together
and you know do a meditation for the
abundance of the restaurant and you know
looking in the window that could be yeah
I mean you're in the mission in San
Francisco it's like you know totally and
you know other things we used to we used
to take a fork to a wineglass in the
middle of the dining room and have
people read the mission statement out
loud or we'd have an RV or we'd do a
minute of laughter because one of the
one of the turns a hostile work
environment otally are you gonna make me
laugh
I do not want to laugh for a minute this
is absurd you know that is how we are as
human beings as adults no I did not that
is so no so we you know and even in
Venice I actually tried to I actually
one night took the whole dining room and
got everybody to do a laughing yoga
exercise where everyone laughed out loud
for a minute
and some people were laughing at us
laughing but that was fine too right so
sorry so walk me through the landmark
thing and the San Francisco restaurant
and like kind of what happened from your
perspective yeah from what happened we
you know we got we were super eager
beaver and like landmark you know my dad
met his wife at Tara Tara C's who was
also the co-founder traffic gratitude
they met at Landmark my dad was
potentially going to become a landmark
forum leader charity was leading
programs at Landmark you know part of
the inspiration of Cafe Gratitude in the
banner of boardgame we came from that
experience you know we had had such
profound experiences of transformation
from this work and again I did it when I
was 18 or not I did it in 1919 it right
around that same time that
transformational point in my life in
this in the second world trade tower the
14th floor and my dad actually resisted
doing it for another 10 years and then
he finally did it when my mom left him
for another woman
and his life fell apart and he that's
actually where he went to kind of put
himself back together that's where he
met Tara C's and then kind of they gave
birth to Cafe Gratitude out of that
experience and again we had just seen so
many people in our lives anyone that had
become friends you know good friends
with us we were always encouraging it
and we were seeing people you know
having total estranged 10 15-year
estranged relationships with family
members totally getting things complete
you know um you know apologizing and
getting resolution around abuse and
addiction and yeah part of the
fundamental paradigm is getting people
to confront their truth to you know kind
of pull down the shades of denial and
then forcing them to have those
uncomfortable conversations with
themselves and with the other people in
which with whom they're in conflict or
have some kind of unresolved trauma in
order to create that healing so that you
can become a more whole human being and
fully integrated
I think the thing that's so profound
about it and the thing that's why I
still recommend it is there's we all
know that we want to be more authentic
but we also know that we're completely
full of it we're so it's just safe and
easy to stay in that place totally and
there's you just can't quite you know it
you want to be authentic you know that
everything is good but yet it's still
safer comfortable and there's more
mental justification for staying's and
going through that program I you know
time and time again I see people
basically putting themselves up on the
cross and acknowledging how full of it
how phony how much how arrogant you know
and and and really owning things that
three days before you couldn't have
imagined they would be able to claim
acknowledge or like point the things
that were so obvious to the room you
know watching them up there and then
them just really acknowledging that and
then having that conversation with
people in their lives who have become
completely estranged from them because
they were so in their righteousness
about their perspective so I still
remember my dad calling me from a
payphone like in the hallway outside of
the you know wherever this was taking
place yeah and having this incredibly
profound conversation with him I mean
this was a really long time ago but I
still remember it because it really was
transformational in our relationship hmm
so but there's a thing like as I
understand it the the the issue came
about because it wasn't like hey we
suggest you go do this it was like you
have to do this there's a difference
totally we we got as I said we were kind
of eager be sure and kind of staunch
about it and we had people who were
managers we weren't making employees or
advocates do it we were encouraging but
we were we were we were making it
mandatory for managers to go do it
seeing that it was like a you know
communication training and people were
in resistance to that and so that that's
like a bridge too far yeah yeah yeah I
mean I I get it I I hope oppo know if I
you know
if I if I went too far with it again it
was it was well intended and I get that
sometimes over-excitement can be not as
perceptive to nuance and to where people
are how come you guys haven't reopened a
Cafe Gratitude in San Francisco well
we've been busy you know seven eight
years we've been down here opened eight
seven restaurants and we still have
gracias Madre that's right still doing
well and really doing business in
California is challenging just the the
amount of legalities and you know again
it's like it sounds terrible like you
know you want workers rights you want
benefits for employees you but it's also
very you know instance like if your text
messaging with a staff member you didn't
have to pay for that cell phone or if
you're cutting someone's shifts you know
you have to give them two weeks notice
before changing shifts where you know
restaurants is like yeah that's
happening moment to moment yeah
so it means California makes it hard for
small business owners yeah so in San
Francisco is even you know even again
better for the worker which again you
know we did eight years there and you
know we had provided 100% health care
for all of our employees even in Marin
County or in different places because we
knew it was the right thing to do but
ultimately you know there was aspects of
overextending ourselves and you know we
what we oftentimes said in the first
round of Cafe Gratitude we were really
focused on the a SS and we forgot about
the P bar and we may as that of
ourselves because you know you know
ultimately we're house without P is just
an ass yeah exactly so yeah we we we we
have considered going back but we just
haven't haven't haven't gotten to it yet
East Coast to Manny's coach York City
Miami yeah yeah got a step out I know
it's happening yeah it's happen time
cool well I love I want to shift gears
in a minute but I do want to acknowledge
in addition to Cafe Gratitude you have
gracias Madre originally in San
Francisco you have one in West Hollywood
here and that place is just insane it's
so freakin good and one of the many
amazing things about it is nowhere will
you see any mention of the fact that it
is even a plant-based restaurant a vegan
restaurant it's just a beautifully
appointed place like the architecture of
the vibe like everything about it is
incredibly inviting when you go in
you're like oh man this place is cool
the food is amazing and that's it and
the place is packed and I would imagine
95 98 percent of the people in there are
not on a plant-based lifestyle trip
they're just looking for a good food out
of cool place totally yeah I mean that
that really has been I mean I'd say that
that's been Cafe Gratitude and gracias
madres roll coming to LA was really how
do we take something that's very fringe
very you know either you're into it or
you're not and making it really opening
the door on plant-based cuisine to
everyone as a you know as a not a Dogma
but kind of a genre and really like yeah
I go and have Italian on Monday nights
and I go or no let's say Monday we'll go
meatless on Mondays we'll go you know
let's go gratitude or gracias on Mondays
and we'll go Thai or go
you know Indian or whatever on the other
dates of the week but it's not like I'm
only a plant-based person so I only go
to cafe graduate I'd say even at Cafe
Gratitude it's maybe 80% of our guests
are just people who know they should be
eating more plants more organic food
more healthy made-from-scratch
high quality food and so they just build
it in as a part of their life versus you
know something that's a superlative
you're either in or you're out
but a Croesus Madra I mean when you're
at gratitude you're getting the bowls
like you you do have the sense like oh
this is super healthy plant facility but
gracias Madre I think there's probably a
lot of people out there and leave and
don't even realize that there was no
meat or dairy in anything that they were
eating like it's because it's just not
it's delicious
regardless totally I mean I think that's
that's reflected in feedback like oh I
went to your restaurants cross seas my I
had the I think these I had the chicken
I had the chicken to topo ever had the
Chicken Flautas you know it's like you
know that's cool I could do yeah yeah
but yes absolutely I'd say that that
restaurant even more so really just is a
bridge for everyone to having a really
great experience you know you have a
margarita and you have chips and guac
and then by the time the food comes you
know you're just in the grits and
there's no like I didn't get anything
there's no missing yeah yeah I think one
of the one of the not issues but one of
the things that you see when you go to
plant-based restaurants is like I eat a
ton of food man like I need a lot of
food so I need big portions I want to
feel like full when I'm leaving and you
know I get that across this Madre like
it's some places I kind of have to eat
before I go and then I have to eat on my
way home you know and I leave beautiful
food at the restaurant but you know it's
it's just not saving me in in in the way
that I think a restaurant needs to if
it's trying to appeal to a broader
cross-section of the population totally
yeah I mean and it's our most by far our
most successful restaurant right you got
any more of those speaking yeah news
flash
we're actually closing the Newport Beach
gratitude and reopening in October so
we're closing September 3rd and
reopening in October or November on the
2nd Southern California gracias Madre
cool in the same location same exact
location refresh redesign and reopening
we think it's gonna be a more
appropriate fit for the Newport Beach
Orange County crowd I mean our most
popular things there are margaritas and
nachos and clearly that they're there
telling you what they want and so yeah
that's actually some big news
company-wide
very excited and you're you're working
on the Agoura Hills Cafe Gratitude - is
that not public no that's actually sage
that's my sister sage okay that was the
one I yeah my sister is sage vegan
Bistro which she has three Organic
plant-based restaurants in LA and you
know people have referred to us as the
vegan mafia yeah but the yeah so she's
opening her fourth in in Granada or no
in Liguria agora yeah yeah right down
the street from yeah I mean I'm
investing I invited you to invest yeah I
know I'm thinking about it exciting man
well I wanna I want to switch gears Oh
actually just oh yes I wanted to
complete the thought which was basically
sacred commerce is the oh yeah we didn't
know profitability awakened and we got
way down the awakening tunnel and went
into cults and stuff but then
sustainability so really we're an
organic 100% organic plant-based
restaurant that serves you know most of
everything we do is from scratch we've
put a ton of time and energy into
sourcing the best ingredients where many
restaurants have two or three vendors we
have 40 50 I think the most we had 70
vendors you know getting you know one or
two ingredients from a different vendor
because we had an emotional attachment
or ethical attachment to where something
was coming from so you know and that's
been you know what we've been you know
doing since day one you know we were
some of the first people to do
cold-pressed juice on the west coast
when cold-pressed juice wasn't even in
the lexicon of understanding you know
cold processed coffee we we actually
sold a blue bottle coffered their first
expressive machine that was from our we
took it out of our place because we were
gonna only do cold processed coffee mmm
and sold it to the Blue Bottle their
first expresso machine in San Francisco
back in the day and so we you know we've
just we've always had a commitment to
food as medicine no amount of pesticide
herbicide fungicide should be in our
food and just have gone to great lengths
to
you know protect you know the
ingredients that we're putting in the
food and and and you know it's down to
the salt it's down to the cumin that's
down to em every legume every nut seed
and really putting energy and defining
where those where those foods can come
from
I would imagine along the way people
would have said to you listen man like
you know you're gonna have to compromise
here and there because you know you're
never gonna be able to scale what you're
doing or reach your profitability goals
when you have so many vendors and you're
so choosy and picky about where this
stuff is coming from like no one's gonna
know the difference like come on yeah
and to be honest I think you know we
have had you know we have had to make
compromises not to say we haven't made
any compromises but those compromises
don't include us going outside of you
know bringing in you know organic
produce organic ingredients you know I
think there's a few items like there's a
beer at one of the untapped that's not a
certified organic product and you know
we do work with some small organic
farmers who are not certified but we've
you know understand their practice
understand what they're doing and you
know we are happy to serve and sell
their produce so when you're trying to
vet these farmers or these sources you
go to the farms are you trying to make
them as local as possible like what is
the the process or the criteria yeah
over the years it's been you know
different things but definitely visiting
having our chef visit farms I've gone
and visited farms you know working with
distributors who are only distributing
organic produce such that we know that
there's not going to be a
bait-and-switch and you know some kind
of hustle there of re stickering things
and saying this conventional and because
there are a lot of that going on yeah
yeah so yeah we over the years you know
obviously we're always trying to focus
on you know California based you know
obviously there's some stuff that's
coming from from Mexico avocados
depending on the season
but you know it's mostly Southern
California some Northern
and then you know if there's you know
nuts and seeds and you know specialty
products like coffee or cacao that's
obviously coming from South America and
other places but again we're working
with companies who are sourcing and
they're doing you know we trust that
they're doing their due diligence on
their and to know where those
ingredients are coming from well sorry
don't rep you I think that's a natural
segue into the the next thing I want to
talk to you about which is regenerative
agriculture and and how you got
interested in this and and kind of where
your head's at right now with it so you
know walk me through this
totally yeah the most the most exciting
thing happening on planet Earth
regenerative agriculture we're coming
we're segwaying from the David Bronner
part of you into the Zac bush part of
you totally so yeah again I I've been
serving selling a proponent of organic
agriculture organic food local food
plant-based food for my whole life I'm
39 years old but professionally been
selling organic food for 15 years in the
restaurants and then even before that
with follow your heart and and I kind of
thought I knew everything not everything
I thought I had a basic understanding of
organic agriculture environmentalism
sustainability you know and I I went to
New Zealand back in 2013 on a trip to
where I was gonna show a film that I had
made called may I be frank which was a
transformational documentary about a guy
you know have a psychic italian-american
dude Frank who's like overweight you
bring him into the restaurant and what's
cool about that I don't want to Ellis
but you wrote too much but what was cool
about that is you would expect okay
you're gonna feed him just great food
and he's gonna lose some weight and all
of that but really it's about his
spiritual transformation like how he has
to reckon with his
yes emotionally and his family yes that
I think is the real heart and beauty of
that yes and I'll just say that the the
aspect and the intention of sacred
commerce really is that at a high level
in it and a deep level of commitment
that that spiritual transformation is
the intention that we are committed to
and have had a desire to fulfill in you
know small micro doses to our guests to
our employees advocates and ultimately
to the business world into the world
watching right so but yeah so may I be
frank we went to I went to New Zealand
to show the film and do a screening and
Frank went with me and with my wife and
I let a little workshop on sacred
commerce and then I ended up in and just
to say I kind of went there a little bit
like an arrogant California and who
thought his [ __ ] didn't stink and he
knew everything about plant-based and
vegan and I know all you know you know I
have compostable this and my packaging
is this and and I had a complete state
change moment where I learned new
information that changed everything and
that was I was sitting in a panel
discussion sitting in the audience just
watching a panel discussion of six
expert scientists talking about the the
the the title the panel was called can
human being sustain themselves on planet
Earth and basically five out of six said
no and that the dire state of things is
far further than we're mostly led to
believe and that you know it was like
people were crying and in the room
people on stage were crying it was like
an emotional and then the last guy spoke
with the sky was by the name of his name
was by Graham sate and he is a
agricultural consultant and kind of soil
site not really a scientist but in-depth
knowledge study of soil science and
plant life and
a train's agronomists and basically said
they're all they're all telling the
truth but there's a blind spot in the
conversation and that blind spot is soil
and its unique ability to sequester and
hold all the excess carbon it's in the
atmosphere be having us up over four
hundred and ten parts per million we can
actually draw that carbon down through
our food choices and create a benefit of
that carbon being in our soil verses a
villain in our atmosphere causing global
warming and I had and and I and I again
I had knew that you know I think we all
knew that photosynthesis you know takes
carbon out of the atmosphere makes
option for us to breathe but the part
that I don't think I didn't get was that
the way that carbon is transferred from
the atmosphere and has been since the
beginning of time to cycle on planet
Earth is that photosynthesis is the
driver of that transference of carbon
and that trees plants grasses every day
every when the sun's out there pulling
carbon in and they're sharing somewhere
between 40 and 60 percent of that carbon
carbon dioxide they're adding water
hydrogen and turning into a carbohydrate
and they build themselves with that
carbon and then they pump forty to sixty
percent of that carbon into the soil and
feed microorganisms and has those
microorganisms eat that carbon sugar
that becomes stable carbon in the soil
so I just you know basically got for the
first time every living plant is on our
side helping us balance this global
challenge that I haven't heard any real
solutions to there's like this kicking
the can down the road to you know
technology saving us one day in the
future but really and we have to reduce
it
missions we have to you know decarbonize
our our energy sector but we're also
over 415 parts per million well I don't
really see then that carbon is not going
anywhere what is the real plan for the
pull back plan and at that moment I saw
oh my god I could see the living skin of
the earth and humans tending to that
living skin of the earth sequestering
that carbon and balancing reversing
global warming and it was like I just
didn't get that functionality I didn't
see how that bigger cycle circle worked
and I got it for the first time it was
like you know there's like these
spiritual moments of like a thousand
suns going off in my mind in my heart
and I literally was like this is true
real and possible and for some reason I
have a role in being a catalyst and a
missionary and a messenger for this new
understanding of soils role regenerative
Agriculture's role as a pathway forward
for Humanity mmm-hmm yeah this idea that
the solution literally resides but you
know underneath our feet yeah it's right
there
and yet humanity has just gotten in the
way and interfered with this very
natural process and if there's a way for
us to revert or get out of the way and
start practicing these things that can
enhance this cycles ability to do what
it already knows how to do we are then
in the solution and not in the problem
that's right and I would even say
there's a sort of a conservation and a
sustainability mindset which is you know
let nature do its thing without us which
I think even the next conscious shift is
how do we because already how do we yeah
how do we participate in this catalyzing
what they call a trophic cascade and an
ecosystem there's this beautiful video
that really demonstrates regeneration
which is when human beings re-released
wolves into Yellowstone National Forest
or part
and essentially because there hadn't
been any predators in that system it
basically the deer started to just hang
out in the valleys and kind of eat away
the grasses and things started do a road
but when they reintroduce the Wolves it
kind of kicked the whole ecosystem into
gear and where everybody was kind of on
each other's toes and everybody was
playing each other's playing a role and
people weren't getting kind of lazy fat
and fat and happy and ultimately costing
you know degradation on the overall
system and within six years after they
released the Wolves into Yellowstone
National it's called how wolves change
rivers if you look it up on YouTube I've
heard of those forty million people have
watched it but it's this unbelievable
phenomenon of how this trophic cascade
happens all through the ecosystem of you
know it becomes more rodents it becomes
more owls there becomes more hawks it
becomes more growth in the trees it
becomes more grasslands that we cut the
roots strengthen and hold the river
going in one direction versus kind of
starting to erode and having the banks
kind of eroding away because the the the
deer had kind of had no no predators no
one moving them around they're kind of
domain and in turn the system started to
what we call it desert if I and so yeah
so the this this you know shift of
consciousness of kind of doing less harm
to how our land management practices
actually enhance ecosystem function and
the carrying capacity of the land and
and just really seeing for the first
time like wow something to proactively
do that actually doesn't just sustain or
slow damage down it actually restores
regenerates and renews which in the
definition of sustainability which is
kind of like our North Star around like
alright we're destroying the planet
let's be sustainable
it's like two
staying something that's already broken
is sustaining something that's broken
broken so or just holding on to
something so that it doesn't break right
as a pair as opposed to being reparative
that's right
that's right yeah I think you know in in
in a macro sense we need to telescope up
from our kind of view of the landscape
and take a much broader view of the
macro system like you can say okay I'm
vegan on plant-based so you know I'm
reducing harm by not eating animals but
if all the food that you're eating is
non-organic or it's being shipped from
faraway locations which obviously has a
huge environmental impact or it's the
result of mono cropping would you're not
really in the solution in the way that
you might might be diluting yourself
that you are right like that is not a
proactive yeah you're you're it's less
harmful than doing other things but it
it's not as far down along the road as
as I think a lot of people think it is
yes yeah I and I and I was a I was kind
of shouting from the rooftops that is
was that your current your understanding
before going to New Zealand yeah I mean
I I thought that the most sustainable
and the best way to preserve the planet
was an organic plant-based diet where I
still think that's a really righteous
path because it's saying no to the
ninety five percent of what is a total
desecration and a total destruction to
so many things including you know animal
welfare including you know the immense
amount of methane that CAFO feedlot
operations put off but again it was
still I still didn't if I if I look in
like my heart of like how are we gonna
get there like it just it was it was
still just like a reactive not
participating versus what is the macro
you know living system of Gaia this you
know living breathing organism
called planet Earth and you know what
are the bigger cycles of that and how do
we support those cycles to be most
abundant and most fertile and I think
you know it's beautifully articulated in
the distinction between you know a lot
of organic agriculture can be seen as oh
you know it's a list it's a list of
practices that you can't use like you
can't use these chemicals you can't use
these fungicides you can't use these
synthetic the synthetic nitrogen whereas
something like biodynamic which would be
kind of an early expression and
articulation of a regenerative
agriculture really saw the whole farm as
a living organism and that you know the
the pollinators the microorganisms in
the soil the earthworms the the owls the
you know the the the whole thing is a
living system and how do we how do we
support that living system to continue
to stay vital and and and and what are
the things that actually enhance soil
life or enhance biodiversity and and
versus just I don't do these things and
really that's regenerative agriculture
is this kind of and again I you know I
just want to acknowledge that you know
what we do what I discovered and what
became kissed the ground with you know
the cofounders of finian and Lauren was
was knowledge that has been kept and
understood from many indigenous cultures
around the world many pioneering you
know pioneering farmers and
permaculturist sand you know this is
wisdom that's been in little pockets for
a long time coming from many places you
know we're standing on the shoulders of
that wisdom and we saw be that being
that we live in Los Angeles and you know
the the communications capital of the
world
trend-setting capital of the world we
said all right this is the most exciting
important idea inspiration pathway we're
going to tell this story we want this to
be a paradigm shift of you know that we
can actually go beyond sustainability we
can actually regenerate and restore our
soils we can restore our biodiversity we
can you know have healthy food for you
know the idea that we can't feed the
world on small ish or even medium-sized
farms is absurd
you know 40% of the food gets wasted 80%
of the food feeding the total population
comes from small farms so walk me
through that because that's that's the
thing and I that I have difficulty
wrapping my head around I mean the
conventional wisdom is look if Kay foes
do one thing it's that they know how to
drive economies of scale like they take
a super concentrated you know number of
animals and they try to blow them up
into food using the least amount of time
and resources possible and they've kind
of perfected this right this is having a
huge deleterious impact on the planet
until suffering all kinds of terrible
issues with that nobody's a fan of this
but when I look at how many people are
on the planet and the forecast for you
know the 10 billion that are soon to
come and then I look at biodynamic
farming my first instinct is we don't
have enough land like you're you need
more space for these cattle like
certainly we're gonna have to reduce our
addiction to animal foods on some level
not everyone's going to get struck vegan
but how can we scale up this this
wonderful practice that is yeah I mean
no super westering carbon and
regenerating the earth and all of that
and do it in a way that actually is
going to function in the modern world
totally I'd say you know my view is that
the the big billboard is we need to eat
more plants eat less meat as like the
the big the biggest billboard that as
far as where we are because 95% of the
meat that we're eating is you know
just a total train wreck but if we want
to get interested in the more nuts and
bolts of how to grow food
in a way that actually restores heals
and not just you know you know the the
aspect of animals and eating animals and
animals role on grasslands and keeping
grasslands healthy and ultimately when
we're talking about keeping grasslands
healthy we're talking about keeping land
that we're growing grains for eating you
know without when we decoupled animals
from land we just put animals in barns
and then we put chemicals to boost the
nitrogen the NPK nitrogen potassium and
phosphorus as like the you know the
quick fix to grow to grow you know
grains and crops essentially the the
chemicals obviously started to degrade
the farmland in the last 40 years we've
lost we've lost 30 percent of the
farmland being grown to desertification
right so destroyed so the United Nations
said we have 60 years left under the
current system of harvests 60 seasons
left so we you know we have to we have
to scale way back I mean right now most
meat that we're eating is you know
coming from a total destruction system
right so we need to cut way back on that
we need to be eating you know more plant
rich diet and then if we're if we're
really serious about how we can actually
restore and heal land and restore the
you know the broken soil you know
animals grazing on grass lands has an
amazing restorative effect and that is a
solution for those that are going to
continue to eat meat and that can be a
something that has a total full
environmental win
for the planet and you know it's showed
that you know a CAFO situation has total
methane a lot of greenhouse gases going
up and a grazing situation where you
have managed grazing of animals on
grassland you have a net sequestration
of carbon going even you know the cows
still produce methane but within that
overall system there is a net
sequestration of carbon and a
significant net sequestration of carbon
going into that land that's being
managed that way so the you know and a
lot of the land that across the country
is not fit for agriculture we don't want
to be telling it we want to put in a new
crop so there's actually and we've
killed all the natural bison or you know
grazing animals oftentimes that were on
that land and so you know there's this
real live opportunity of you know
putting grazing animals back to a good
life and having a net beneficial you
know impact on that on that soil on that
grassland on that environment and you
know we're obviously you know
encouraging you know a less meat
consumption but for the people that are
gonna eat me this is an opportunity for
that to have a beneficial impact and
again I get the morality aspect of you
know people not wanting to kill animals
and I love and respect that perspective
but for those that are those that are
choosing to eat meat here is a really a
win-win situation that can have a
benefit for for for many stakeholders
yeah including you know the thing the
biggest thing that we don't have a
solution for which is how are we gonna
sequester enough carbon such that we
don't go into climate chaos yeah we need
some emergency actions right now we
really are running out of time
and things like the farm bill and these
subsidies are really preventing us from
embracing a solution that's right in
front of us like you know it seems to me
that if
could stop subsidizing the you know the
growing of all these crops that go to
feed and we can start emphasizing
biodynamic farming the price of meats
gonna go way up and that's gonna call
the herd literally in terms of like the
number of humans that can afford these
meat products it's going to drive down
meat consumption and make that
possibility more realistic but there
doesn't seem to be any political will
for this that's the problem
there's there is not but I'll tell you
since since we started kissed the ground
seven years ago and we launched the soil
story which was the first piece of media
that we that you know that I had seen
that was like a three minute short
synopsis of regenerative agriculture and
the potential of it
the amount of attention and turn people
using the terminology and the amount of
investment going into that space is been
I mean it still it still has drop in the
bucket but you know the fact that
General Mills you know making a public
declaration people could say all that's
total green wash you know a million
acres you know by 2030 another startup
called indigo just committed to I think
you know 10 million acres under
regenerative management and they're
wanting to pay farmers to sequester
carbon you know the the the momentum
that when we first started talking about
this it was very fringe and and again I
didn't know it you know people like you
know my understanding is Al Gore people
were very experts on you know climate
people you know Bill McKibben you know
had understanding of this but they
weren't standing like this was a
solution it was still too fringe it
wasn't but now there's an article every
week that's got coming out talking about
how farmers can be a solution to climate
change yeah
so the great thing about it is that it
embraces the farming community I think
one of the problems with the you know
this movement in some regards is that it
embitters the farming community because
they feel like they've been positioned
as the enemy right whereas this is
saying let's embrace our farmers and
help them create
better more profitable life for
themselves with greater yields like the
big lie in all of this is that we've had
to make this transition into factory
farming because that's the only way to
get the yields and and as all of your
work shows and the documentaries in the
advocacy and all of that it's just not
true
like when they make this switch to a you
know a biodynamic approach it was
calling we're calling it regenerative
regenerated agriculture it is it another
form of regenerative agriculture so yeah
so you know the things I'd love to share
you know cuz the kind of the work that
we've been doing over you know seven
years there as you said it's you know
it's been a lot of we've kind of been
looking at you know how do we how do we
shift critical math to understand this
such that actions you know people start
adopting actions business start taking
this on this becomes you know the way
that we're growing food fiber and fuel
is through a regenerative perspective
and how can we have our ecosystems being
restored
well we're producing the goods that we
need for free humanity and you know the
the the good news is is that farmers can
make a lot more money you know we're not
talking about you know it's not a get
rich you know by no means but there's a
lot of evidence and a lot of examples of
where farmers have gone down this path
and made the successful transition and
you know they're not going from it from
an alter ism or like save the planet or
even if they even believe in climate
change but they're going from a place of
I'm watching my family farm
you know degrade I'm watching people get
sick I'm watching I'm watching I need to
get more equipment bigger pieces of land
you know I think you know a fact that
the same amount of nitrogen fertilizer
to grow one bushel of wheat in 1970 is
now tripled so you have to use three
times the amount of nitrogen to get the
same bush
of corn in in present day so you know
number one the number one profession
that has suicide high suicide rates is
farmers and essentially the opportunity
here is that in the next because the
average age of the farmer especially in
this country is between you know 60 65
68 years old in the next 10 years
there's gonna be you know one of the
biggest land transfers you know since we
can remember and if in that transition
we have the precedent of regenerative
agriculture is the way and people in the
way that young people are excited to get
into business and entrepreneurship and
businesses that have a purpose which is
you know a lot of young people don't
want to just be part of the status quo
business corporation blah blah blah they
want to be just like kids don't want to
be a part of the farming system which is
just chemicals corn soy and sending it
to you know China or ethanol or you know
to make ethanol whatever there's an
opportunity to have the farmer be the
hero that we can actually restore our
landscapes and restore our food system
restore our climate and and farmers can
help make a little more more coin on it
yeah that's cool and you're seeing that
I mean you are seeing lots of young
people who are excited about this like
when I was in college like no one was
interested in this and now all these
young people getting graduate degrees
and and in this field and you know going
to work on these farms it's it's pretty
cool like it is happening it's it's it's
happening you know you know I'll just
tell you you know some of the two
programs that we've really landed on
that we're really thrilled about is the
first is we have an advocacy training
program because we saw wow I learned
some new information and I became a
catalyst for so much so how do we grow
this army of you know messengers because
right now the environmentalist it's
there's not really an exciting path
there's not a pathway for an
environmentalist to feel lit up you're
still just kind of fighting against and
a system that's beyond winning
whereas the context of regeneration the
North Star of regeneration is like you
can actually see the active
participation you can see the way
forward from it and so we've trained
over the last year 1400 people have paid
us to do to come and do a six-week
course on Tuesdays and you can do it in
person in LA or online really
beautifully well set up you know online
or and from 25 countries and now we have
advocates taking on projects you know
all over the world that are lit up about
this possibility the possibility of
regeneration regenerative agriculture
and you know things like you know the
Rodale Institute which is one of the
longest standing kind of organic it's
actually they corn the term regenerative
many many years ago you know we got a
call from the executive director Jeff
foyer saying you know we've been doing
this for 50 years and I kept on here and
kiss the ground advocacy like you know
the way you're communicating is is
working people are getting it they're
getting inspired and we got another call
from another woman who's in the course
right now saying you know I used to be
an environmentalist raising millions of
dollars and kind of just gave up and now
with this paradigm shift and
understanding of regeneration that we
can actually reverse the damage done and
it's actually you know we're already in
manipulation and management of the skin
of the earth the majority of the skin
through agriculture and we can actually
I can see how that healing can actually
be a solution for you know the the
crisis that we're in and so you know
it's just in so we're basically training
people to to be advocate so we're also
you know Jeff from a commune Jeff
Krasnow yeah wanderlust area we did a
free course on commune that's coming out
I can look up the day did you shoot it
up in the up in Topanga it is pretty
full up they're a super super cool and
so that is that's happening it's a free
10-day course September 9th on one
commune calm
so yeah we're basically we have two
programs we're training advocates to be
professional spokespeople on behalf of
soil regenerative agriculture and then
you know giving people pathways to
participate in their own communities and
how they can you know take action and
then the other big problem project that
we're doing is a farmland training
program where we're basically sponsoring
farmers a three-year program so for
eight thousand bucks we can take a
farmer with you know ten acres to five
thousand acres and basically put them
through a three-year training program
that has an in-person course and then
consulting through the three year the
three years and a soil test to know
their baseline you know where they're at
with their soil health and then at three
years and so you know people you can
fund you can fund a farmer through our
work and that basically facilitates the
farmer to go through that transition
process that's super
so yeah those are those are our main two
programs is training farmers and
training advocates to really be you know
the because we you know we understand
that to shift a paradigm you have to
have you know early adopters and then
when you get like 14% you know then you
can kind of get this bigger so we're
seeing you know again even speaking here
on your on your show is kind of like how
do I you know connect to influential
people get this to become their
narrative and a story that they're
caring where they speak and they
communicate as well as training you know
any individual in a more long-term right
and then the final thing is we've been
co-producing a feature-length film with
Josh and Rebecca two cow filmmakers who
made the film fuel that won at Sundance
about ten years ago and the film is
called kiss the ground and it's showing
some of the best examples nationally in
this country of regenerative agriculture
being done at scale and showing the you
know incredible results of you know what
people are experiencing from you know
ecosystem restoration as well as from
the economic opportunity yeah the
interesting thing is how quickly it
turns around right like how how
rapid you you when done right how rapid
it you can regenerate the soil and
create biodiversity in in the ground and
the impact that that that has on water
absorption and you know a whole litany
of things that have downstream impact on
improving our environmental health yeah
I mean when you heal the soil you heal
the the ability for water to recharge
our aquifers right right now right now
it just runs on runs off goes into our
tributaries and into our waterways
creates these algal blooms it's terrible
terrible so your your your recharging
aquifers you're you're putting
nutrient-dense food on people's plates
you're getting rid of you know cat all
the chemical inputs that are being that
are you know ultimately going downstream
as you've just described and your and
your your creating a regeneration of you
know an economic system for farmers who
are you know essentially died i mean
they're they're literally struggling
massively
so you know it's such a such a win-win
situation and that's why you know when i
when it when it when i saw it and I just
got it it was just like wow this is what
my life is for mmm-hmm and who's the one
farmer who was saying he was getting
0.5% to 1% Alan Williams yeah I mean
remarkable and three-year period on a
5,000 acre ranch he was able to triple
his forage so basically he was able to
bring grassland that was very spotty and
almost kind of desertified basically
tripled the amount of grasses and
basically through his adaptive
rotational grazing of animals of cows he
was able to basically regenerate the the
forage which is the food for the cows
three times such that he could have
three times more cattle on that on that
piece on that one
piece of land so ultimately you know the
neighbors is like spotty almost you know
completely desertified growing corn and
soy and he's taken a land that's been
that that over some many years and then
every year putting somewhere between
four to ten tons of carbon sequestered
in the ground able to produce more food
per acre because we've tripled he's
basically tripled his forage on on that
land and so he's totally you know is is
the ecosystem services have been
regenerated his is the economic
opportunity has been regenerated and
essentially you know the the we're just
in an orthodoxy that is you know we need
chemicals we need big AG we need these
to feed the planet to feed the world and
you know as we as we you know train
farmers and create communities of
farmers because to have multiple farmers
in an area together having a success
then that becomes a very powerful symbol
and reputation for people to you know
maybe make that transition because as as
as are all people you know we're all
we're all stubborn in our own ways we
think we've been doing things the right
way and it's hard to change right
speaking of stubborn like how do you how
do you square philosophically this work
that you're doing with kiss the ground
with the fact that you're like an
impresario of the plant-based lifestyle
and V this vegan restaurant Empire like
you know part of me feels like I get it
but also like let's move away from the
cows you know what I mean like and I'm
sure you're on the receiving end of
criticism like hey you're supposed to be
this vegan guy but you're talking about
sequestering carbon in these farms by
virtue of grazing right so how do you
think about that or respond to that yeah
I mean that's been a big that's been a
big - lamian I don't know if you
remember we there was this whole yeah
kind of
big controversy big controversy we had
six weeks of protests and people you
know saying my family are murderers and
it was intense and yeah I mean you know
I think the thing that we as human
beings the thing that we most dislike is
when people know new information but
continued a lot of your face based on
you know it's good for business to do
that this was not good for business to
tell the story of hey we went we moved
to we went to open bila farm as raw food
vegans and we were you know figuring out
how to grow vegetables for our vegan
restaurant realizing Wow to grow vegan
vegetables we need remnants of animals
nitrogen manure either coming from a
CAFO situation of you know a really
terrible situation or you know blood
meal bone meal fish emulsion and you
know reckoning like wow a lot of these
vegetables that you know were you know
making up our vegan diet are coming from
the fertilization of the decomposition
of dead animals and so that was like a
big kind of shocker and there's no way
to grow those vegetables otherwise in a
scalable way I mean there's there's
there's Agriculture called veganic
agriculture which you know I think it's
a beautiful you know I think that people
have made that they're like they're
they're they're edge and they're doing
it but if you look to bio dynamics and
you know all the all the organic
pioneers of agriculture that really were
thinking and holism and whole cycle
systems and really seeing how do we make
agriculture
mimic nature because most monoculture or
grain or vegetable production is tilled
monoculture vegetables grains legumes
and essentially the way you fertilize
that is you work in partnership with
animals to graze over that and re
fertilize but again inside of you know
everything has to bring something to the
table and you know people are farmers
they're you know they're they're
cultivating food to have it be a way
that they can cultivate food as well as
an economic opportunity you know for us
it was like all right we we saw we'd
rather steward cows and have them be
able to eat our grass and fertilize our
soil versus getting CAFO manure from
down the road or fish emulsion from Lake
Superior and you know some people eat
meat on the farm some people and just
felt like all right we're we're humbly
learning how to grow organic food in the
most sustainable or regenerative way
looking to the forefathers of that
wisdom and what we're understanding and
what makes sense oh wow there is this
architecture of life and death that's
always been in nature that has cycling
nutrients and well there is life and
death in that in that system
there's overall a a proliferation of
more life and life continues not as a
you know not like there's not
individuals that die but the overall
system remains healthy and continues to
rejuvenate itself and so you know as we
walk through that process ourselves and
you know my dad Ben 40-year veteran I
had been vegetarian for 35 years and I'm
still mostly I live mostly you know 90
percent a plant-based lifestyle
and eat plant-based diet because it's
what I've eaten for my life and I feel
good on it but I hope people would honor
that we we went to learn how to do it
you know and do it ourselves and growing
food and what we came to to create this
21 acres of you know and and to have
this continual regenerative effect it
was going to require you know the the
grazing of animals and the fertilization
of those animals and to to pay for the
cost of that you know whether it's they
bring milk to the table as an income
opportunity or meat or bone you know
there's you know everything has to you
know every in in a farming system we're
harvesting crops to sell it dance kind
of the the the system so you know I get
what felt like a really hard
almost betrayal from like hey you guys
were the vegan family and and you know
and I get that there's like this
disappointment when you feel like you
someone embodies something or you think
they embody something and this is what
they represent for you and then they say
hey I changed my mind alright I'm doing
something different but again I would I
would just hope that people would have
to respect that you know we're just
telling the truth of what we're learning
and we're in our process of
understanding what is the the best way
to care for you know this living planet
and have it be continuously alive and
vital and you know in that system death
has always been a part of that yeah it's
uh I mean certainly I'm no expert on
agriculture and farming and these issues
but I think as humans we have this
impulse to be reductive in our reasoning
and you know the vegan community
obviously didn't there was a portion of
it that didn't embrace this you know
this this fact as you know as welcoming
as
as I would think that you would have
wished and it's hard you know I think
life and issues like this are more
complicated and nuanced and again it
goes back to telescoping out and trying
to look at these things from 10,000 feet
and grappling with you know what the
best possible solution is I mean if
you're you can be the most ardent
hardcore militant vegan of all time but
if you're you know consuming a
ridiculous amount of single-use plastics
I mean I just saw a news article he was
yesterday that it was snowing plastic in
the Arctic like then are you really in
the solution like there's always more
things that we can do we all have blind
spots and sometimes the the truth of
these matters is a little bit more
nuanced and complicated than we would
wish it to be totally yeah you know I
mean this was this was terrible for
business to like you know share this
story were like boycotted and there were
all kinds of articles about this when it
happened
yeah yeah it was but then you know
telescoping out like you're the guys who
are who are serving up more plant-based
meals than almost anybody on the planet
so it's right you in the solution are
you in the problem you know these these
answers are not there you know there's a
lot of gray it's not everything is black
and white totally right and again we you
know five 10 years from now you know III
hope there'll be an evolution in the
story of you know that I'm telling and
you know what we've continued to learn
as we've explored down this path and
understanding the the process of
regeneration and the you know the
importance of animals in that system and
it's yeah it's just what what we
understand at this point and you know I
I hope that I continue to be able to
tell the truth about the process mm-hmm
well there's certainly plenty that we
can all agree on and that is that we are
running out of time that we are
definitely in the midst of a insane
cataclysmic environment
crisis that actions need to be taken
they need to be taken swiftly and
intelligently we do need to reduce our
you know our meat consumption our
plastic consumption we need to live more
sustainably and we need to live more in
rhythm with nature's you know Gestalt
and we've moved so far away from that
and I'm heartened by the younger
generations desire to live more Purpose
Driven lives and and the care that that
that you know people younger than myself
tend to tend to take for the planet that
my generation has failed to do so and so
I remain hopeful and optimistic but also
tentative because so much work remains
to be done do you know Charles
Eisenstein has he ever been on your show
oh you know his name or now it sounds
familiar
he was about to beautiful books one
called the beautiful world our hearts
know as possible hmm and then one called
climate a new story but a really
beautiful philosopher thinker like a
modern day you know brilliant mind of
our time and you know he quotes tick
tock hans term of interbeing which
really i think - you know as far as how
do we how do we live in reverence and
appreciation and understanding that we
are all part of a life-and-death cycle
and how can we be grateful and
appreciative you know whether it's
plants or animals that you know die and
we consume to create our life how can we
live in reverence and appreciation of
that that process of life and death is
the architecture of this universe and
every time we do have a meal whether it
is plants or animals and you know even
the best and vegan meal required you
know a system of cropping that
ultimately killed lots of beings and you
know can we be in reverence of you know
that we engage and
are participating in this universe with
that architecture and can we be grateful
and do our best to make sure that we're
caring for those things that we require
along the way and that those that
require you know that we require to
consume into - you know sustain our
lives and I think there's a beautiful
quote by a guy named Wendell Barry who's
kind of a godfather of natural farming
and he's also a poet and he said every
day we break the body and spill the
blood of creation if we do it knowingly
carefully and reverently it is a
sacrament if we do it with greed
gluttony and carelessness it is a
desecration hmm and yeah I mean that to
me the big the big wake up is it's not
just you know it it's not just one thing
it's it's it's our relationship to all
things and how do we live more in an
awareness of interconnection and
awareness of gratitude for everything
that supports our life and then when we
are grateful for it
you know the inclination is to care for
it and want it to have its best
expression of life that it can have its
kiss the ground which comes from Rumi
that's right the name of your child am i
right yeah what is the full quote the
full quote is let the beauty you love be
all that you do there's hundreds of ways
to kneel and kiss the ground beautiful I
think that's a good place to round this
out awesome thank you for the work that
you do and that you continue to do it's
been inspiring being in your orbit over
the years I can't remember when we first
met it was many years ago we just
continued to cross paths and our friend
Circle definitely overlaps and I can
always count on a hug from you when I
walk into the restaurant you're not
always there but you're they're quite
you're you're there more than I would
suspect right though
yes and and with everything that you're
doing with kiss the ground so if people
are listening and they want to learn
more and get involved with kiss the
ground yeah we love everyone to become a
soil advocate it's the new environmental
movement see the regeneration generation
the regeneration generation so yeah our
soil advocacy training you can find that
on kiss the ground calm
follow us on AG Instagram kiss the
ground at kiss the ground and then fun
to farmer if you're inspired by this
story and we just got you know someone
just just got an anonymous fun - farmer
$8,000 arrived this morning I think
someone who just said wow I want to fund
a farmer towards regeneration so for
eight thousand bucks we can have a
farmer be on the path to regenerating
their land and it's very it's very
exciting it's similar to farmers
footprint a little bit yeah we're a
fiscal sponsor oh you are okay so we're
very connecting with Zach Busch and
their whole team and stuff yeah nice man
and what's coming up on the horizon
what's coming up on the horizon let's
see kiss the ground wise the
feature-length film narrated by Woody
Harrelson coming out last quarter of
this year so we're still working on
what's the distribution plan for it but
the film is done so very very excited
about that the yeah please we have a
couple more soil advocacy trainings this
year so jump in that and as I said fun
to farmer and then on the Cafe Gratitude
front we have a meatless Monday's which
is kind of like why are you guys
meatless Mondays your meatless every day
but we're basically encouraging
omnivores and carnivores to come and
have a great plant-based experience and
we'll pick up half the tab so we
basically every week at all of our
restaurants we have two or three items
or two items that are 50% off as a way
to encourage you know for everybody or
only if you declare yourself to be an
omnivore no no for everybody but you I
mean you have to you have to join our
loyalty program but basically yeah every
Monday and we've encouraged tokaiya to
take it on and they might jump on sage
might take it on as a way to yeah I mean
meatless Monday's is a you know it's a
it's a cool way to shift the collective
consciousness to have you know one day a
week where we say all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna take care of my body and I'm
gonna take care of the planet by not
consuming you know you know what is
oftentimes the most destructive food on
the planet so and then another cool
thing we're doing a partnership with
Jaden Smith this is kind of an upgrade
to the gratitude Bowl uh-huh
it's called the I Love You Bowl and it's
gonna be a dish that'll be kind of his
favorite you know meal in a bowl a pink
bowl which is kind of his color and it
will say I love you on the bottom of the
bowl and for every bowl that you buy in
the restaurant we'll feed one homeless
meal that same bowl off of his truck
truck I love you both cause he's got the
I Love You truck I love you I was
wondering whether you guys might be
behind that so yeah it you know he said
there was parts of it that were inspired
by Cafe Gratitude
but when I saw him do it I called him
and he was like let's do this yeah and
so we're now in the development we're
aiming to launch at the last quarter of
the year and hopefully serve 10,000
bowls we can give away 10,000 that's
cool that's amazing how cool is that kid
unbelievable what a what a bright heart
center yeah I mean being present that
whole family yeah beautiful so that's
happening we're doing we're
collaborating with Mark Hyman we're
doing a one week sugar-free detox so
five days starting in September
September 15th and then the following
week you can do five days it's gonna be
like fifty or sixty five dollars a day
and all your nourishment for the day
really well curated yummy plant-based
amazing nutrient-dense food - sugar and
you get to see how you feel after you
know going a week no sugar so that's
that's happening and and then
Thanksgivings coming up we'll do our
free Thanksgiving again we're going to
do at the Venice locate
that's gonna be happening so please come
down for a really really beautiful heart
centered community Thanksgiving we have
live music and it's just a total place
to belong you feel like you belong
so come for that and yeah I love you and
thanks for listening and thanks rich for
this amazing opportunity to share I love
you too Ryland thank you for sharing you
are amazingly grounded and centered and
present and calm amidst all the amazing
things that you're doing which is a
whole other podcast conversation that we
could have about how you comport
yourself in the world but I respect you
so much
I'm in awe of what you've created and
it's an honor to talk to you today so
thanks man cool so uh web sites all that
kind of stuff kiss the ground yeah send
it to you later no just tell me where oh
cool so love being Ryland is my that's
actually my my my first a bounding river
board game named love being Ryland so
it's an abundance word a spirit word in
my name and I chose it as my Instagram
handle because I'm I love doing I love
being Ryland is my personal Instagram
and at Cafe Gratitude at gracias Madre
at gratitude kitchen and bar which are
third restaurant actually that's another
cool thing that's happening is we just
hired a brand new chef for the gratitude
in Beverly Hills and our gonna kind of
totally revolutionize that menu are nice
so it'll be not kind of it'll I mean
it'll be foundationally gratitude
quality ingredients but like on the next
level culinary expression guy named
Jason would so really excited about that
and then as far as Instagram it's at at
kiss the ground kiss the ground calm is
you know that the web site there and
then I said Cafe Gratitude calm gracias
Madre calm and gratitude kitchen and bar
calm
I think that is yeah that's it I think
we did it we did it how do you feel I
feel great no good so great we did good
right yeah that is really uh yeah I was
I was concerned how the whole meet
conversation was gonna come up as tricky
yeah but we had we had a good we have
yet the only way out is through my
totally and we walk through it totally
no I felt it felt it felt it felt
honoring and and and responsible and
truthful and yeah all right cool
well come back and talk to me again
sometime amazing all right I just I just
I figured I'd tell you this news just in
orcas island this past weekend yeah for
the first time beautiful place by the
way but I talked to Mike Posner while I
was there oh you did the last time I
talked get it on the Mike I got to hear
this okay come talk to Mike before after
the rattlesnake bite after the
rattlesnake yeah after the rattlesnake
bite he told me he told me play-by-play
the whole story mitts it's a miraculous
story I mean he is like hurting dude
like he got I mean you see the video of
him and you're like this is not no joke
yeah could be a month plus of ribéry and
yeah just beauties in an amazing space
about it he he you know he sees the
opportunity to he sees it as the perfect
temptation for giving up or stopping or
having total justification but the
positivity with which he's he's walking
through this is so impactful for
everybody that loves and follows him
because look at this guy like look what
happened to him and still he checks in
every single day and he's like happy and
forward-looking and all of that and it's
it's like I spire to that yeah he is
level of character beautiful being and
he's doing great and he's gonna walk it
out and I'm gonna meet him in Venice for
his final it's final strike I'll join
you I was thinking of flying out and
joining him for Astra you know part of
the walk Oh awesome
yeah
I had got up before the light though I'm
like this dude is taking his time like
yeah he's still like in the middle of
the country how long is this gonna go on
for you know you could be out there for
like an entire year yes point I think
his I think he what he I think he's what
30 days 30 or 60 days from after after
he comes back two months right 31 one or
two months I think but I know in queue
you know in Cuba yeah yeah good friend
of his I was gonna meet him on Lincoln
or something to do the final stretch oh
well I'm definitely there for that I'm
gonna I'm gonna inner I'd love to do
that final stretch with him yeah
absolutely
cool yeah but it came up because the
last podcast I listened to of your show
was it was his episode with you which is
awesome he's supposed yeah so amazing
cool all right all right man
[Music]